now if you are looking for a surprise
weapon against the move default then you
came to the right place as in today's
lecture not only I'm going to show you
some cool tricks and traps in the
Cambridge Spring but overall I'm going
to cover a mini replied so you can
literally use this line as a complete
surprise weapon in the tournament
practice
[Music]
thank you
afterwards D4
it doesn't matter whether you are Knight
to F6 or D5 player the beauty is
this line can be reached from both the
opening choices
here black choose the move D5 and after
C4
indeed black goes with the Queen's
Gambit decline structure starting with
E6
so now both the players follow the mail
line for a while Knight to C3 Knight to
F6 Bishop to G5 and now rather than
playing the traditional Bishop to E7
black plays this very tricky move Knight
to D7 which in fact create a small trap
that if white thinks that he can wince
the pawn here
as the night has spin then
congratulations as he fall into the
Queens can be declined elephant trap and
I'm sure all of you are aware of it that
black can take this Knight
sacrificing the whole Queen
but the net result is after Bishop to B
for check
Queen to D2 Bishop takes King takes and
finally when black king take the bishop
if you carefully count the pieces black
is a clear piece up
so this is a famous elephant trap which
you should aware of it and if white fall
for it then the game can be finished
very quickly
okay the main line continues with E3
liberating the last Bishop
and we are going to respond with C6
and after Knight to F3 the Cambridge
Spring occurs on the board with the
following move Queen to a Phi
whereupon we reach to the most critical
Junction of this line
so as I have highlighted over here white
has plenty of options and amongst them
Knight to D2 is the in fact Main Line
however there are also some Sidelines
starting with C captures D5 as well as
Bishop to F6
but first thing first
you will be very surprised that most
natural move at this position such as
Bishop to E2 Bishop to D3 and queen to
C2 immediately leads to tricky territory
where black in fact get the upper hand
at the opening stage
let's see how
well the first move I want to consider
is Bishop to D3 well after that we have
this nice sequence D capture C4
Bishop capture C4 and now you pressurize
this Knight as well as the bishop by
playing Knight to E4
well obviously enough white has to save
the bishop and it doesn't matter
wherever it moves
the next sequence is pretty obvious
Knight takes E3 if Queen to D2 then
Bishop to B4 is a very strong reply so
by force white has to take back this
Knight
but after Queen captures C3
Knight to D2 is force in order to
preserve the bishop but now black
simplify the whole position with Bishop
to B4 Rook to C1 after some exchanges
finally when you count the material at
this point black emerged with a clear
Pawn advantage
well the same story goes for the move
Bishop to E2 as after this we have once
again this little pin and when white
Defenders with Queen to C2
what else this lovely Knight to E4
giving great headache to the white Cam
they cannot move the Rook as we can
simply Chop It Off
and apart from it the basement suggested
by engine here is white shoot Castle on
the king side but after that yup you
guessed it we have multiple exchanges
whereupon our Knight is attacking the
bishop and when white defended we can
continue with Pawn Tech seafoam Bishop
takes E4 and Knight to B6 where the end
result again shows that black emerged
with a clear Pawn advantage
so you can see if white moves the light
Square Bishop then he straight away lose
the vital Pawn at the opening stage
the third move Queen to C2 I faced most
oftenly in this line and I can't tell
you how many people fall for this
as once again we can create the winning
tactic based on the spin and the move
black should start with is Knight to E4
so double attack
and there is a small cute trap here if
white continue with Bishop to D3 which
seems like a logical response
but unfortunately this straight away
loses the piece
can you find the sequence
pause the video if you need more time
I'm showing you right now
it's the double attack Motif and it goes
as follow Knight captures G5 Knight
captures G5 and I hope you indeed see D
capture C4
which highlight how crafty this opening
is for the white
well apart from Bishop to D3
what can once again move the bishop
somewhere let's say Bishop to F4 but as
usual after Bishop to B4 white loses the
vital Pawn as after Rook to C1 and the
move Queen captures A2 again and again
in this line black winced upon at the
opening stage and white has absolutely
no compensation
for example one of my recent game
against 1900 finished very quickly where
my opponent continued with Bishop to D3
I simply exchange on C3 and after Pawn
takes Queen takes Rook takes
black simplified the position more with
d capture C4 and after the multiple
exchanges
at the end result if you count the
material black is a vital Pawn up
with a clearly Superior position
okay let's start with the sideline moves
and the fourth alternative I want to
consider here is Bishop takes F6
so white says hang on
all the tactics is based on that poor
Bishop so let me exchange it and now I
am going to continue with my normal
developments such as Bishop to D3
and my position is completely safe
right
value up to some extent that's true but
still black is not out of the Venom as
after our Bishop to B4
okay white cannot play Rook to C1 but he
can indeed defend the Knight with Queen
to C2
but exactly here we can show the power
of our position
starting with Pawn Tech C4 Bishop takes
C4 and now this lovely move C5
which I think already give black some
huge problems
well it doesn't matter whether White
Castle or clay D capture C5 both leads
to the problematic position
for example if we take the pawn then
after the following sequels
Bishop to D7
Castle on the king side and as soon as
the Knight become unpained we Chop It
Off
so that after Pawn takes Queen takes it
doesn't matter wherever the light Square
Bishop goes our next plan is pretty
obvious we Castle on the king side and
as I have highlighted here black has a
very simple but effective plan of
campaign
he can Target the weak C3 pawn and in a
long run it is only black who enjoys the
attack and the fund here
well the same story goes if he goes with
the castle which is in fact as per the
database most popular choice
can you find the same sequence
let's see first we start with C captures
D4
well obviously if you take back with the
E Pawn then he get an isolated Pawn so
the majority of the games continue with
Knight captures D4 but still this leads
to our familiar territory
yup you take on C3 Pawn takes C3 and
after Castle once again we have a very
simple plan based on this weak C3 Pawn
so as you can see this bishop to F6 line
doesn't give anything to the white Cam
except the weak C3 Pawn
the fifth alternative I want to consider
is C captures D5
and here if you look at the database
black has plenty of choices
but I'm going to recommend you capture
back with the e-pawn
so that our light Square Bishop get
liberated
and I think this line not only instantly
equalize for the black
but along the line he has some nasty
ideas
for example if you look at the most
popular choice by white Bishop to D3
we can start with this very aggressive
Knight to E4
and after this once again what else but
white is having some issues
there's a small trap here if your
opponent take this Knight
which looks very obvious but after Pawn
takes E4
why two pieces are hanging
and I just like to show you a grand
master game from this position
which demonstrate how quickly black get
the advantage
white plays Knight to E5 black Chop It
Off
and after Bishop to B4
even with the base sequence that is
Castle
Knight takes E4 white could not hold his
position as black demonstrate the
problem in this position namely Queen
captures E5 not only attacking the two
PCS but don't forget the B2 Pawn hangs
and this has exactly happened in the
game after F3 black first played Bishop
to F5 and after Bishop to F4 he indeed
grabbed the pawn where the end result is
black emerge with a clearly winning
position
so this is a nice trap you should
remember when your opponent plays the
move Bishop to D3
well apart from capturing this Knight
white can Castle or play the move Queen
to C2
both leads to a very comfortable
position for black
for example let's say castle is probably
the most aggressive response here
and White's idea is that after Knight
takes G5 Knight takes D5 and the Moon
Knight to F6
if anything slow then black can take out
the Bishops and castle on the king side
so the best response for the white here
is to play E4 open up the position
but I don't think so this is working out
well
as black can take this pawn and Destroy
White's Bluff
for example a sample line can goes like
this Knight takes E4 Knight takes E4
Knight takes E4 and now Bishop to E7
so that when white plays Rook to even we
can safely castle and if you look at the
end result not only black has a bishop
pair but white has an iqp which as per
the results clearly favors the black
last but not least let's look at the
main line starting with Knight to D2
and after this even though black has
plenty of choices I'm going to recommend
this straightforward move Bishop to B4
so we are already hitting the C3
so why need to defend it and after this
black can complete his development with
castle and meeting the mainline move
Bishop to E2
with this nasty jab in the center
yup if I
and to be honest this is what attract me
to play this aggressive line
here white has plenty of options but
neither of them gives any advantage
for example they can continue with
Bishop takes F6 thinking that black
cannot capture back with the Knight well
guess what this is exactly we are going
to deliver
as after d kept Z5
we have this nice move Knight to E4
which once again
create some problems for the world
would you believe recently I beat a
title player in this line
where both the side played some obvious
moves and at the end white find himself
at the trouble Zone
Knight takes E4
Pawn takes E4
he cannot take the pawn as C3 Knight
hangs with a check
so he Castle
but as soon as the night become one pain
we have a simple maths yup you take this
Knight and even though after Queen
Exchange
after Rook to E8 this end game already
looks so wonderful for the black
why well the answer is very obvious
white has some fracture Pawn on the
queen side and black is about to regain
his material back
well my opponent tried to hang on to it
for a while he played Rook to Devon
I played King to fade
and now he attack on e4 but as the king
is safe this is now easy for black
I took on E5 and after this check my
Rook simply drops back
after Rook to Devon Bishop to E6 Rook to
D4 and the mufai finally black
consolidate his position and because of
White's horrible Pawn structure on the
queen side at the end I finally managed
to win
so I think this game is a moral
demonstration what kind of disaster
white is having if he goes forth
islamine
the second move I want to consider is D
captures E5
and the idea is that if black take this
Pawn then white can destroy the black
king side
but nope here black has an equally good
reply namely Knight to E4 our old friend
pressurizing the C3 so why response is
false he has to take it off
but once again we have this nice
sequence
Pawn takes E4
Castle on the king side
Bishop takes C3
if Queen takes Pawn here then after
Queen exchange and Knight takes E5
once again with the bonus fracture Queen
Side Pawn
so that's not a good idea for the white
that means he has to take back with the
pawn and after this we have a very
simple sequence
Knight takes E5
quintix E4
here I rather than capturing the C3 Pawn
black should play this tricky move in
Knight to G6
whereupon it doesn't matter wherever the
bishop moves
our goal is to complete our peace
development with some tactical ideas
for example there is a game in the
database where white continue with Queen
to D4 defending the pawn
but now comes Knight takes a fool Pawn
takes F4 but the end result is
yup you know it I don't need to repeat
it and I think we should see this game
that how quickly black get the upper
hand as in the game black demonstrate
how bad white position is
starting with Rook a to d8
surprisingly after Queen to E5
black goes for the queen trade which at
First Sight looks like repairing the
white Pawn but clearly he has seen the
position in depth as after Rook to D2
Rook to even and now Rook to C2
confirms black advantage
as in the game white plays the move Rook
a to C1 but this leads to the losing of
a pawn and after Rook to A1
blacks simply exchanged the rook and
play Rook to E8 where in a long run the
a pawn is a clear winner
last but not least
the most popular choice here is Castle
on the king side which I'm really
surprised as it allowed what black wants
to do namely he captures D4
if you take back with the pawn then you
get an isolated ball
so nope that's not the point
white wants to play Knight to B3
so that when the queen moves he can take
back with the Knight
but in this line tactics favors the
black as we can still inflect the double
Pawn in the white Cam by playing Bishop
capture C3
obviously Queen capture C3 goes into the
blunder house as Knight to E4 wins the
piece
so no that's not an idea and white has
to forcefully take back with the pawn
that means after Pawn takes E4 Bishop
takes C4
we achieve what we want to do not only
isolating the white coincide Pawn
structure but we have some tactics on
the table starting with Queen to C5
okay there is a double attack so white
response is force white has to take on
F6
but after Queen capture C4
I think black is in a completely driver
seat
and to illustrate my point there is a
quick win from the Black from this
position where white continued with
Bishop to E7 attacking the rook and
after Rook to E8
he doesn't like the idea of Knight
coming forward so he played Bishop to D6
but after Knight to F6 black Liberate
the last piece and in fact in the game
white plays rooked to B1
thinking that he is stopping the bishop
movement but this leads to the instant
losing position
can you find the killer blow here
congratulations if you see the move
Knight to E4
and after this
no matter whatever white plays he get a
completely losing position
he cannot play Bishop to B4 because of
the simple tactic C5
so that is right out of the equation
and the only other alternative is moving
the bishop on the king side
well after that yup you guessed the
result black wins the vital pawn and
then slowly converted the full point
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this high profile tricky line of
the complete spring
you can do the more research in this
line and maybe find more tricks and
traps but I'm sure I have given enough
info to play this line confidently in
your own game
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and I will see you in my next episode
very soon
buy and take care